So here you have goals
you're trying to accomplish,
sort of positive things you're trying
to do and then you have constraints.
Basically I want you to eat little dots,
eat big dots and
eat big ghosts while honoring
the constraint that I don't want you
to be eaten by a non-scared ghost.
>> Okay, yeah, I mean so
now from a logic standpoint,
we've covered everything.
Success and
things that are defined by success and
things that are defined by failure.
>> Right, and but the failure here,
I mean well, right, in exactly that way.
So why did I bring all this up?
I brought it up becausem one I just
think it's kind of neat that people
actually come up with these things.
But the other thing that I think is
kind of neat is that it gives us a hint,
it gives us two hints actually.
It gives us a hint about how we might
do a better job than just simply
behaving randomly in our rollout policy.
So here's something you might do.
You might say when I get down to here,
rather than behaving randomly.
And where by the way, I sometimes will
get eaten by a ghost even though I
could've easily avoided it.
I'm going to try to behave
randomly while still
honoring whatever constraints
I happen to have defined.
So here, rather than trying to just
walk around until something bad happens.
I'm going to try to stay
alive as long as possible
which is what this constraint tells me.
And that's a different kind of
roll-out policy, but one that I
claim that gives you a sort of better
view of the goodness of this state.
This state action pair is better
because you can avoid violating your
constraints for longer than if you are
say in this state and take this action.
And there are lots of other
things that you might do.
I just sort of wanted to give you
a flavor of it which is that I can use
these sort of options if they are of
a certain type in order to be smarter
about the way I do my roll-out policy.
There's also another way
that we can do this.
I can still use options in general,
in this entire search up here before.
Rather than taking primitive action and
doing my search through the tree in my
expansion, I can replace this with
my actions with options as well.
Ooh.
And what's the big win there?
Well the big win there is,
by following the options,
I'm getting deeper into the tree.
>> Yeah,
it's the same kind of idea as in
the option case that we
talked about already.
Except now we're in trees instead of,
I guess, grids.
Yes, but trees and grids,
it turns out they're all the same thing.
So there's lots of things
you can talk about.
There's been a lot of
work in this space.
Some of them are available as
readings for the students.
I recommend thinking about them but
what's I think kind of nice about
it is that this general notion of
treatingm solving an MDP not as
just I've got to solve the MDP,
but as a kind of tree search problem
where we take advantage of and use
the randomness is something that unifies
a lot of approaches that you might have.
>> Okay, cool.
>> Okay.
And I think that's pretty much.
I'll say one more thing about this and
then I think we're done and
that's just that there are lots
of ways of looking at this.
You might ask yourself is this
even reinforcement learning,
where we've just gone back to searching
and I'm going to claim it is.
I'm going to claim it's
a policy search algorithm.
>> What's your justification for that?
>> Well, my justification for that is,
I'm basically by building this up,
I am doing,
I am searching over possible policies.
And what I'm doing in the inner
loop of searching for
policies is I'm doing a kind
of reinforcement learning
step here when I do my backups and
in fact, the way you do the backups is
you use the Bellman equation as
a way of re=estimating Q values.
And once I have those I now have
another policy that I'm looking at and
I just keep dong that over and
over again.
So I'm really searching through policy
space which is sort of what the tree
expansion is.
And I have an inner loop
every time I run out of
my confidence about the policy.
I'm doing a little bit of
reinforcement learning to figure out
what the policy ought to be.
So it's policy search with an inner
loop of evaluation, sort of.
>> And
Monte Carlo policy evaluation somehow.
>> Right, exactly.
Well that's really what it is and the
way I'm doing the policy evaluation is
by doing this well,
doing the Monte Carlo.
>> So it really combines a lot of
ideas that we've talked about
into kind of one algorithm.
Has this been successful?
>> It has been successful.
I've actually used it in my own work.
It has this really neat feature
that allows you to avoid
searching over lots and
lots of the state space.
It's actually really wonderful.
It actually has a couple of
properties that are worth mentioning.
So let me mention those properties and
then I think we're done.